[Musique]
une vraie force de la nature à 29 ans
caddie baradji réalise en moyenne de 25
heures de sport par semaine et peut
soulever jusqu'à 80 kg des performances
qui lui ont permis de devenir miss
fitness france à créteil en novembre
dernier
j'avais vraiment envie de me dépasser 2
d'arriver au bout et de le dire je fais
tout ce que je pouvais que je gagne ou
pas en fait de d'être allé au bout de
moi même dans une compétition où c'était
pas mon domaine en fait pour réaliser
cet exploit cet ancien athlète et
tenniswoman d'un mètre soixante huit
pour 60 kg a dû remporter plusieurs
épreuves sur une journée un concours
loin d'être une promenade de santé
il y avait des séances de force qu'avec
squat développé couché
il y avait des pompes à des tractions
des abdos des lombaires et un gros
circuit un peu cheap comme ce que je
viens de faire là et c'était vraiment
complet pour remporter ces épreuves
spartiates kddi a travaillé pendant un
mois de façon intense avec son
entraîneur dans cette salle de maurepas
je savais qu'elle allait gagner
sans aucun doute c'est fou tout le temps
sourit tout le temps
zumba la danse tennis 3 feet fitness
tout ce qu'ils roulaient en permanence
musculation le jour et encore du sport
le soir en parallèle de ces grosses
séances de fitness caddie donne des
cours de pilates de renforcement
musculaire et surtout de zumba cinq fois
par semaine entre voisins le bretonneux
et montigny le bretonneux
allez les filles on y va c'est parti
pour moi personnellement je préfère
faire les pompes et les tractions met à
enseigner à la zumba c'est vraiment très
sympa ça allie la dépense physique et le
plaisir en fait c'est à dire que c'est
vraiment un fun on se rend pas compte
qu'on est dans l'effort
[Musique]
chaque soir une vingtaine d'élèves
viennent participer à ces sessions ce
sont eux qui l'ont poussé à s'inscrire
au concours miss fitness france la
victoire de la professeur a donc été
accueillie avec de grands sourires
abba en est fier on est fiers pour nous
aussi on la met sur un niveau supérieur
l'histoire de caddie avec le monde du
sport n'est pas prête de se terminer la
sportive envisage de défendre son titre
de miss fitness france l'année prochaine
et de participer à d'autres concours